hello students at Danny Jones middle
school this is Selena Gomez talking to
you Selena Gomez making a surprise
return to her old middle school in Texas
this trip I wanted to take my bus from
Courtney and also some of my people from
my label just to show them where I grew
up and how proud I am where I'm from and
some of my teachers I got to see again
and they were part of my life for so
long in the video Selena's old teachers
also reflect on what she was like when
she was in school she had a really kind
soft spirit hard hard worker I honestly
didn't think it would go as well as it
did I'm really happy
twenty-seven-year-old also shared advice
for current students and I think it's
also important to make sure that you're
being kind to someone and to see them
eating alone like I did here you know
just to say hi and just encourage them
in their schoolwork and know that no
word on how long Selena plans to stay in
Texas but her BFF Courtney just shared
this post fulfilling that Whataburger
crazy
[Music]
the payer and some other pals recently
headed to a Kacey Musgraves concert it's
pretty clear Selena's been focused on
her friends and her music I love you
guys so much and everything's good yeah
Selena's anticipated album is completed
we're just waiting for her to release it
yes
finally done I'm just nervous about it
honestly because I feel like the next
few choices that I'm gonna make are very
crucial so I'm trying to be really
really diligent and just patient with
everything a source previously told ete
she'll release it later this year and
that it'll be super personal quote
Selena has gone through a lot over the
years and is ready to share it with the
world
[Music]